es ist die tatwaffe mit dieser
schrotflinte und mit diesem berger
jagdgewehr sein andreas es zwei
polizisten erschossen haben jetzt wurden
sie im prozess ein polizistenmord von
kusel vor gericht gezeigt diese waffen
klar ist der 24-jährige die 24-jährige
polizeianwärterin jasmin b und den
29-jährigen oberkommissar alexander k
sie wurden mit schüssen aus diesen
läufen ermordet doch wer hat geschossen
es gibt schmauchspuren die aber noch
nicht genug beweisen ja und weitere
grausame details kommen vor gericht ans
licht wie eiskalt der 39 jährige andreas
s offenbar ist das zeigt vor allem dass
nachdem er die junge polizeianwärterin
tod glaubt durchsucht er sie nach einem
notizbuch das ihn belasten könnte dabei
bemerkt er dass sie noch lebt und
schießt ihr ein weiteres mal in den kopf
schon zu beginn des prozesses weiß
andreas es alle schuld von sich
behauptete dreist aus notwehr gehandelt
zu haben nun versucht er den mord seinem
komplizen florian v in die schuhe zu
schieben der ebenfalls auf der
anklagebank sitzt für nv gibt
unterdessen alles auf andreas es dem
eben die waffen gehörten er bisher steht
allerdings nur andreas es wegen mordes
vor gericht der mordvorwurf gegen
florian f der wurde bereits fallen
gelassene er befindet sich auf freiem
fuß der polizisten doppelmord von kusel
ein verbrechen das an brutalität und
grausamkeit wohl kaum zu übertreffen ist
ein urteil wird nicht vor dem herbst
erwartet